as the 4th US president to face an
impeachment threat Donald Trump is
scrambling to elude history it's a joke
no president yet has been removed from
office through impeachment on Wednesday
the United States 45th President
sounding unusually subdued seemed to
feel history's wait its first said what
the Democrats are doing to this country
they're dividing they're belittling
they're demeaning our country so many
leaders came up to me today and they
said sir what you go through no
president has ever gone through the
White House's own account of a July
phone call between President Trump and
Ukrainian president Vladimir's olenski
was released Wednesday it revealed that
as Trump was withholding 250 million
dollars in aid from Ukraine he
repeatedly asked zalenski for in his
words a favor investigate former Vice
President Joe Biden's Trump's potential
presidential rivals Trump asked zalenski
to coordinate the probe with US Attorney
General Bill Barr and Trump's personal
lawyer Rudy Giuliani Trump without
offering evidence accuses Biden of
ending a conflict-of-interest probe into
his son hunter Biden took a lucrative
position on the board of Ukraine's
biggest gas company in 2014 while his
father was directing US policy there in
the summary of the phone calls olenski
promised his top prosecutor in his words
we'll look into the situation but with
trumpet his side ukraine's leader says
he did not pursue it I'm sorry but I
don't want to be involved to democratic
often elections I can't push anyone you
know that's it that's the question that
is the answer
a whistleblower in the US intelligence
community alarmed by Trump's apparent
use of state power for political gain
reported the president's call to an
inspector general however the complaint
was not passed on to Congress under
instruction from the White House and the
Justice Department
amid the furor it has now been passed to
lawmakers
I found the allegations deeply
disturbing
I also found them very credible like
understand why the inspector general
found them credible the House
Intelligence Committee received the
whistleblower report on Wednesday on
Thursday Acting Director of National
Intelligence Joseph McGuire testifies
before Congress that session is now part
of a formal impeachment inquiry into the
president asked about the call Trump
repeatedly turned the focus on Biden
fully support transparency on the
so-called whistleblower information even
though it was supposedly secondhand
information which is sort of interesting
but also insist on transparency from Joe
Biden and his son hunter on the millions
of dollars that have been quickly and
easily taken out of Ukraine and China
now Trump's efforts to prompt an
investigation into his rival have
instead helped to prompt another
historic probe one intended to decide
whether he is fit to remain in office
John Hendren al Jazeera Washington